britney spears future as a performer is
now in question
as she squares off with her father in
court and of course her fans have a lot
to say about this
our lauren zeme is in the middle of all
the madness down at the courthouse and
joins us now
yes the free britney movement is out in
full force here in downtown l.a you can
hear them protesting behind me
as the pop star fights for who will
control her life
our common goal is to free brittany
brittany
sees a light at the end of this very
dark tunnel
that's what her former makeup artist
exclusively told et
as brittany goes to war with her dad
today fighting to get greater autonomy
but the biggest reveal in the court
documents
[Music]
britney wants to stop performing
that's right the year 38-year-old loves
to dance on instagram but
court documents say that britney has not
resumed performing and has stated she
does not desire to do so
what's the fallout drastic changes to
her budget
if brittany wanted this conservatorship
to truly be over
at this point she needs to let the court
know and show the court
that she's able to take care of herself
britney should be prepared for this
conservatorship to go on indefinitely
if brit does get more control of her
life from her father
how does that affect her sons jaden and
preston and her ex
kevin federline well the boys actually
spend 70 percent of their time
with their dad me and britt are good e.t
spoke exclusively to k-fed's powerhouse
divorce attorney mark vinson kaplan
who says kevin's happy with how they're
co-parenting according to a source the
dj gets nearly 40 grand a month in child
support
he's all for brittany taking
responsibility in whatever level she
feels
capable and comfortable of doing
brittany is not his enemy and he's not
brittany's enemy
and as for the influence of the big free
britney movement
the judge will not be swayed by public
opinion on this very private situation
kevin only knows
what we all see in the media about that
i can assure you
that the probate court and the
conservator
is not going to be persuaded in how they
discharge their duty
by a grassroots appeal from a group such
as that